here's three reasons why i'm not that
excited about the bitcoin futures etf
number one large inflows doesn't
necessarily mean higher bitcoin prices
this is because the etf buys cash
settled futures contracts rather than
buying bitcoin from the spot market
number two is expensive so these
contracts expire and if you believe that
the price of bitcoin is going to go up
and so you want to remain invested you
need to sell that contract and buy one
which expires at a later date but that
contract which expires at a later date
can be even more expensive so it kind of
defeats the purpose of buying low and
selling high and number three the
futures market can be very difficult for
the retail investor it can become
overwhelming and complicated the retail
investor is not going to look at this as
an opportunity to get into bitcoin
overall i'm not that impressed with the
bitcoin futures etf one of the main
reasons futures markets exist is because
storage selling and everything like that
can be very difficult when it comes to
things like oil but with bitcoin it's
super easy to store so i would just say
take self custody and buy the actual
bitcoin